novembre 2021 la cour suprême de
colombie examine une requête d'une ong
d'activistes la cause juste qui
revendique le droit à l'avortement la
colombie est un pays plutôt conservateur
et très catholique et l'opposition à ce
droit s'exprime fortement pour des
motifs religieux le foulard vert est
devenu partout le signe de ralliement
des partisans du libre choix ce sont les
verts qui gagnent
en février dernier la cour suprême
dépénalise avortement jusqu'à 24
semaines de grossesse karosas rouste à
aurait préféré la dépénalisation totale
mais le progrès et la
cour la colombie est aujourd'hui un pays
plus juste pour les femmes avec moins de
discrimination et qui nous reconnaît
comme êtres humains libres et égaux
réaction prévisible de l'archevêque de
bogota et san andres et qu elle était la
ville et devons respecter l'avis dès la
gestation et jusqu'à la mort naturelle
le président yvan douter lui utilise le
mot atroce algo temps atroce comme mon
père me dit que s'interrompt pas en
arrière assad rose de permettre
l'interruption d'une vie jusqu'à six
mois de gestation les colombiennes
reviennent de loin
l'américain corey la new labour taux
auxquels ces logiciels et la femme qui
avortaient risquait jusqu'à six ans de
prison dit le médecin chef de profanes
il ya jusqu'en 2006
avant les avortements étaient
clandestins et le docteur vargas a vu
bien des cas de complications sévères et
de mort de très jeunes femmes
d
donc à partir de 2006 dans le réseau
privé de cliniques pro familia qui
depuis 1965 se consacre à la
planification familiale
ils se pratiquent des avortements
mais à trois conditions pour qu'il soit
légal en cas de violences sexuelles de
danger pour le foetus ou pour la santé
de la mère santé physique ou mentale
notion bien large qui permettait un
avortement sur avis d'un médecin
relativement facile à obtenir seize ans
plus tard il suffit de se présenter à la
clinique hacké mon amour est retiré et
il faut cliquer sur la case qui dit
interruption volontaire de grossesse et
le nom de la patiente devient un code
anonyme elle consulte un médecin qui lui
prescrit une interruption chimique ou
physique selon l'avancement de la
grossesse l'intervention a lieu le
lendemain
c'est une procédure souple et surtout
basé sur le droit à l'information et le
libre choix des psychologues sont à la
disposition des patients le canada
finance le programme valiente de pro
familia qui aide les jeunes à assumer
leurs droits sexuels et reproductifs
l'accès légal à l'avortement a fait des
progrès spectaculaires un peu partout en
amérique latine ces dernières années il
est légal depuis longtemps à cuba en
uruguay dans certaines parties du
mexique en argentine plus récent en
bolivie au chili sous certaines
conditions il reste difficile au pérou
et au brésil une région demeure
particulièrement répressive c'est
l'amérique centrale jean-michel le
prince serait du canada bogota